if you are a parent who is going to be
home with your children all summer long
I have the best hack for you I got
access to Khan Academy's con Migo and it
is like having a tutor in your back
pocket it helps you learn anything you
can imagine and it doesn't just help you
learn it helps you understand things if
you got something wrong and how to fix
it additionally most of you know I'm a
teacher and I'm so burned out by summer
that I don't want to do school stuff
with my kids or think about it so I
asked Khan mego to come up with a four
week plan based in the science of
reading activities for my first grader
for five days a week at 15 minutes a day
and it laid it out for me holy smokes
zero thinking for me zero effort